hoy se esperan más evacuaciones de la
acería de mariupol donde todavía hay
menores y civiles atrapados desde hace
casi dos meses en esos pasadizos y que
necesitan ser evacuados urgentemente el
ejército ruso está disparando contra esa
zona pero están moviendo sus tropas
hacia la zona norte hacia esta región de
zamorilla donde nos encontramos
de hecho las tropas rusas ya controlan
la central nuclear de zamorilla que es
la más importante de europa y está a
apenas unos 40 kilómetros de donde nos
encontramos en estos momentos también en
la zona sur en heart son las tropas
rusas intentan avanzar para tomar el
control de nicola jeff y en odessa hoy
han disparado contra un dron que estaba
sobrevolando la zona todas estas
operaciones militares entran dentro de
esa segunda fase que ya avisó el
gobierno ruso para para controlar el sur
de este país pero donde se concentra
ahora la intensidad de toda la guerra es
en el este en la batalla del donbass en
dones y lugares es allí donde se está
intensificando los combates y donde el
ejército ruso está intentando
el ejército ucraniano que todavía
resiste